I'm not joined by Henry Kevin Platon
initiator of the Fair Pay Alliance and
economist and Fair Pay activist welcome
to the studio Henry could the German
sadistic office says that three-quarters
of the gender pay gap is explainable by
factors like part-time work woman's job
choices and all that the adjusted gender
pay gap is just fifty five point six
percent it's still a gap but nothing to
write home about really well people
going on strike for less than 5% so
where's the problem and also you said
that it's explainable the difference
between the five or six to the twenty
one if you can explain it why don't we
solve it that's a very good question but
if we're looking at these these 5.6
percent that we cannot be explained what
are the reasons for that for example I
think lots of different things play into
those percentage because that's the
reason why you can't explain it so one
of the main factors I think is actually
transparency discrimination in a certain
way even not straightforward
discrimination because I wanted to but
the indirect discrimination is part of
it what's that for example you give an
example of that well like for example
when you applaud you you apply for a job
and you talk to the person that is
hiring you and if you are a man or women
you will be put in different sort of
kind of cupboards depending on what you
say so it's an indirect way how the
other person decides if she likes you or
she doesn't like it's not on purpose
that the woman at that point might get
less it's just like a categorization
that I'm opening in my head and those
rows stereotypes play part that you
can't explain you can't say oh that's
1.5% it's something that is there we
know about that role stereotypes are
very hard to put into figures but we all
know they exist and with transparency
it's the same we don't know where it
plays in it will play in it every point
if I don't know what I earn or I can't
compare myself so that's also part for
my sense for the unexplained rest it's
often said that women do sell themselves
too cheaply to employers what do you say
to that they don't that they don't
negotiate hard enough
well they do negotiate differently than
men negotiate that for once
that's that's true because it just
because you look man they can the
trouble is if they do that the reaction
isn't in their favor if a woman starts
to react like a man and to negotiate
like a men they will say oh she's crazy
she's a bit too aggressive she's
whatsoever so you're not supposed to be
like that as a woman people expect a
different way of talk a different way of
giving herself from women and men and
that's why you just can't say women need
to act like men it will not solve the
problem
talika I think this is a very important
point raised in that reported families
is still usually the woman that takes
out time from the job to raise the kids
is that changing well it's supposed to
be changing slowly it is but it's not
fast enough and if you look at the
report and you see that a man doesn't
want to be seen once to state that he
does that anonymously you can really see
that there's still something very very
wrong in society and in our heads and I
believe that we can only change that or
the point when we reach sort of equality
at that stage for fathers and mothers is
when for a company the risk if they hire
a man or the woman is the same I know
the men can't get the child but very
fast after they can make the decision
who stays home and if that's equal the
companies will not sort of tend to sort
of say oh we take the men because of the
risk of the woman the risk has to be
equal we're looking at the situation in
Germany in Western Europe in the Western
world but if we think about the Arab
world Africa many parts of Asia are we
talking about first world problems here
maybe sometimes it's like that it
sometimes feels like that they have the
sensation in countries where everything
is sort of great and you have all
possibilities it's very comfortable the
wages are high it's enough if one works
usually it has to be the guy working
though because the woman is earning less
so she will always stay at home if the
wages are unequal and then it gives you
that sensation but there are countries
where you wouldn't even think about it
like Tunisia Forex
where it's absolutely normal that women
are in business they have their own
companies they are in top positions so I
think it's a matter of really looking at
the world as one world and try to see
what do others already do and why does
it come that in Tunisia for example this
part is a lot better than in Germany we
can learn from Tunisia in this case do
we need to force families to make
decisions like the father stays at home
or should that be negotiated inside
families briefly if you can yeah I think
it should be negotiated inside the
family but on a fair basis you have to
give them the possibility to negotiate
fairly which means if the waitress are
unequal if we have a gender pay gap of
21 percent it will always be in the
negotiation process of the family that
in the end the woman might stay home
because of the higher wage so I think
you can't you shouldn't push it but you
should give them the fair base to
negotiate I'll think of a plan thank you
very much for joining me mister